putin's offered a behind-the-scenes look
at talks to end the nagorno-karabakh
conflict the russian president explained
a peace deal between
armenia and azerbaijan could have been
reached weeks ago
but one of the nations was reluctant to
concede
contrary to popular opinion there
did not store on october 19th and 20th
i had a series of phone conversations
with president aliyev and prime minister
pashanyan
at that time the armed forces of
azerbaijan had regained control
over an insignificant southern part of
karabakh
in general i managed to convince
president elieve that it was possible to
stop the hostilities
but his obligatory condition was the
return of refugees
including to shusha then unexpectedly
for me
the position of our armenian partners
was formulated in such a way
that it was unacceptable for them the
prime minister told me back then
no we cannot agree to this we will fight
therefore accusations against him
of some kind of betrayal have no basis
the truth is widely seen as a
capitulation in armenia triggering
protests and demands the prime minister
quits
there's a different mood in azerbaijan
keeps its military gains and this month
will receive
three other districts in the disputed
karabakh region
but vladimir putin says ending the
bloodshed makes it a win-win
somewhere the most important thing
that's been done
is to stop the bloodshed over 4 000
people died according to official data
in reality i think there are more tens
of thousands have been injured and
maimed
this is not a movie this is a tragedy
that is taking place in real life
with real people affecting real families
therefore stopping the bloodshed is the
key thing
author and historian gerald horne told
us how the armenian premier's u-turn on
the truce cost him
national support keep in mind
that when the prime minister of armenia
uh went into this
war this conflict with azerbaijan that
has
left to the deaths of thousands to the
maiming and injuries
of tens of thousands to the creation of
displaced
persons and refugees a significant
percentage of the armenian population
not to mention the armenian diaspora was
in the prime minister's corner but as is
often said
a victory has a thousand parents
and defeat is an orphan and so now you
see
that a number of the armenians who were
cheering on the prime minister
when he launched this conflict or when
he entered into this conflict
now are ready to see him take the
nearest and closest exit refugees
meanwhile continue to return to karabakh
under the protection of russian
peacekeepers
on tuesday 500 armenians traveled back
to their homes having fled the fighting
1 700 people have now gone back to the
key city of stepanakert
and expressed thanks for russian support
we feel that we aren't alone anymore we
are supported
we've been given our lives back i'm
happy that russia is with me i have
nothing to add i've always respected
russia
and i have nothing to lose i feel happy
and proud
that we have friends like this that help
us and don't leave us in trouble
russian peacekeepers have reopened the
only road link between armenia and the
region
region to ensure the safe return of
civilians
the missions also helped to improve
cooperation between armenian and azeri
troops in karabakh
rt's morad ghaziaf sends us this report
on the peacekeeping work
just north of sushi the site of some of
the bloodiest and most
merciless fighting of this war is a
russian peacekeeper outpost
they arrived to a scene from a nightmare
roads lined with bodies and bombs burned
and blasted vehicles after weeks of
failure
a ceasefire was eventually reached on
the 10th of november
it was full of compromise where armenia
agreed to hand over various territories
it controlled to azerbaijan
the latter agreed to let ethnic armenian
refugees
return to their homes but signing papers
is
one thing making sure things actually
happen
is another one of the benefits of the
two dozen or so
uh russian cease-fire monitoring
stations that have been set up here in
the gonda karabakh
is that they're neutral territories
they're areas where azerbaijani troops
just
a few hundred meters away from us can
come as well as armenian uh
forces and they can resolve their
disputes with the help of
russian peacekeepers as mediators there
are also areas where the red cross can
come
for example to do its own work such as
organize the exchange of prisoners the
exchange
of the remains of fallen troops or
coordinate demining operations
it's all about trust peacekeepers
serve an important function sure they
discourage
ceasefire violations
but that only gets you so far what they
shine at is getting those who waged war
to build peace to that end
humanitarian groups have flocked to
karabakh
the red cross being at the forefront
roads and passes once littered with
bodies and traps and mines
are safe again but what breeds even more
optimism is that armenians and
azerbaijanis
can gather at the same place and talk
if for now through russian peacekeepers
morad gazdev rt nagornica
you